yeah
morning everyone sorry I'm feeling extra
vocally today extra extra I'm just
feeling so inspired from seeing a night
of pure [ __ ] talent at the prime J
concert I'm excited to hear about it I
watched some of your stories but I just
fully sub I've watched all my stories as
much as you guys had posted before I
went right okay no I'm really late yes
checking and then it was almost like
10:45 point five is when she went on and
I need to go home and watch the actual
prime date concert cause like I need to
find myself in the background cuz
apparently me and Margo were quite
visible
I saw it didn't show stars no but I want
to see like on my TV yeah I'm finally
I'll be on TV I think you like people
send me a video that you guys were on
the screen because was her and then
you're in the background I thought you
got screen time of like you guys dancing
no no I think it even though we should
have you should yeah yeah they only did
this fifties in the front apparently
there was like a rule not to wear
stripes but I didn't hear about that
rule because I unintentionally like was
a backup singer Oh where'd the backup
singers when she was wearing pink
stripes and then bring sparkly stripes
and that everyone behind her was wearing
pink purple sparkles and I was literally
wearing pink purple striped so you are
background dancer I mean the singer
actually um I was in paid or anything
but you know I do that you're sweet how
was it Janice and Stannis the second
okay was just like okay let's just talk
about even before she went on because
first of all I don't know like literally
who who in upper management allowed me
to be invited because it wasn't like
influencer central like I saw Andi
Dorfman and that was it I didn't see any
other influencers so it wasn't like they
were being thirsty trying to get like
you know everyone to come and post like
they literally treated us like royalty
like I just I don't know if it was
Amazon if it was autumn communications
like whoever invited me like thank you
so much not only that whoever respected
the hell out of me because they put me
in a private box and right when Taylor
went on ggod than her family comes out
and I'm like oh I guess I mean like
Taylor's box like literally it was so
crazy it was so we're so close to the
stage and the three performers before
were super interesting cuz I want to
talk about to Aleppo for a second yeah
she went on first which I thought was
really interesting I thought they would
go from small to big s and like making
her maybe second or third yeah cuz baby
yeah actually it's it's so interesting
because they live stream to globally
like 200 countries like Becky G was the
perfect person for it and like the
energy in the stadium
now and their theater room what's it
like wasn't there for for Becky G
because it was mostly Taylor's chance
and I don't think they have a similar
audience like she's quite a performer
and she's snatched his hell and she has
the gap in her toothpicks which I kind
of miss but she's so pretty and like I
didn't know any for music but like I
wanted was she singing in the shower
no and she kept saying like they just
don't change my life I was like I'm
ready it was just not a song I'd ever
heard before Wow which was really
disappointing but like I should have to
say like I have respect for Becky G now
like she has a bustling career that we
just don't know about in America I've
always had respect for Becky G every
time she comes on my release radar with
a new song I always give it a try and
it's just not for me you know because
it's now I think she does like
overwhelmingly Spanish songs yeah
and I'm happy to see her thriving she
knows she's thriving then I want to talk
about Julie pop because obviously like
I'd like to a lip I just as someone who
like loves pop culture like I was like
I'll probably know like a good amount of
her songs and I was really blown away by
Julie but like first of all I know every
song every word I didn't even know there
were songs that I thought Jessica Lynn
saying and I was like oh no it's too
early but literally and she is so
beautiful like I'm so like snatched
body-wise and she's an amazing dancer
like she is actually a triple threat
yeah is thinking like this girl's gonna
have like a real legit career because
first of all like her voice is so good
and she doesn't sing with a back track
or like her songs are so good and like
she sings in the same genre all the time
like it's just like she knows what she's
good at dance club music yeah her and
her dancers are so cute she literally
such a good dancer she was making me
like when I take dance classes yeah
right like she was just like moved like
to the right knee was just like and she
had rhythm
swag I don't know what it was she was so
good I really enjoyed her sisse was was
being weird because she was like
refusing she like sings straight to the
audience like she had her back to us
literally the whole time and to the
camera I didn't know what it looked like
on camera but like in the audience she
was like we might as well not have been
there and what I have to say about that
I'm some prime concert is it was made
for TV but like there might as well not
have been cameras they're like
everywhere every performer they had was
so connected with the audience but also
with the cameras and it was just really
impressive I forgot that Taylor was
streaming to all these countries but
sisse
she just didn't have like the stage
presence that everyone else did I don't
know what it looked like on on the
stream because I didn't watch it but
just being in the audience like I've
literally forgot she was on it sounded
like background music because
she was literally hiding from the
audience like literally like this but
she sang a cover of so kiss me dude like
that nightly song yeah it was really
good
cute she's an amazing voice doesn't mean
you know it's um Sixpence None the
Richer it was a great song selection
she's a really great voice um I'm sure
now if I listen to her music like on
spotify I like it but her stage presence
like there it wasn't there for me yeah
they can ariana grande moment worse
because I'm sorry gonna dance yeah no I
literally saw scissors back the whole
time
yeah um then Taylor just like came on
and blew our minds like normally like I
would've been annoyed like I got there
literally three hours later Taylor went
on but like I was just so excited oh
sorry before we even go Jane Lynch the
hardest working woman in Hollywood I'm
so good at her job you have no idea how
hard her job was because she was reading
from the teleprompter basically doing
stand-up but nobody in the audience was
listening people are gonna get drinks it
was so loud but she was really talking
with the camera and like she was playing
to the audience and no one was listening
I just had so much respect for because
it was such a hard job and she did it
seamlessly and every time she walked
offstage she would be right in the wings
waiting to get back on stage when they
did like an Amazon commercial she said
hi to every single person took a picture
with all the kids like was she is
literally like who you think she is do
you know what I mean yeah she's the
hardest working woman in Hollywood and
she was so sweet like I couldn't get
over how like usually the cameras go
down and like the celebrities I can't
either makeup touched up and like not
talking to anyone
Jane Lynch didn't stop working when the
cameras were down that's so nice to hear
I was watching her the whole time I was
really like impressed by her work ethic
you know somebody needing a paramedic
because they got - oh my god yeah like
really girl at the prime they selected
Adam literally millions of people wanna
come and you're gonna black out before
Taylor went on it and the paramedic had
to come and take her away you know it
was embarrassing but also like what he
then do it do better it was really
disappointing I'm sad for her um okay
then Taylor came out and just like not
that I needed any sort of like you know
cementation in my stand hood but like if
I did last night was it you know what I
mean she first of all like anyone who
ever says she doesn't have a good voice
like please she was not saying with
backtracks like and at the reputation
tour she did just cuz I guess it's so
many people that like you need more of
like a whatever but it's around Sam yeah
but she was just so on with her vocals
her body oh my god
not an ounce of cellulite literally her
shorts were so far up her vagina like
any normal person would have had
cellulite no her light side looked like
so good and I so Ted so healthy yeah
yeah that's really getting your story
they looked but I was noticing in my
stories like they looked bigger as I was
a video guys like I want to take those
thighs and just like put my head between
like they're perfect I couldn't stop
looking at her like then every one of my
stories was like oh my god she's singing
to you she kept pointing and like I was
literally standing right next to Gigi
Hadid and Taylor was actually singing to
Gigi Hadid the whole time like pointing
singing like certain lines like they
have obviously like inside jokes and so
I like that I really thought it was
maybe like it wasn't and I like
respected the hell out of their
friendship and teller did a good job
with like making Gigi feel like scene
while also like nobody else realized
they were like having these moments
except for me because I was like right
there you know Damien yeah like I find
it annoying when people like sing to
their mom and like sing to the crowd
yeah but Taylor did a good job of like
balancing both the setlist
what did she sing well so she did ok
here's what the Swifties were saying so
she did an acoustic version of welcome
to New York which is not a usual part of
like her Wango Tango like greatest hit
but we're in New York where New York but
she wants you to feel welcome she said
this one this is the song I wrote about
New York actually this is the first song
I wrote about New York which makes me
think now that unlevered there's a song
about New York which is great I love
welcome to New Era considering my
favorite song and there's so many like
iconic lines that Taylor has and like
this was really swifty crowd Steve so
many Stevie Swifties were there like
really we were they accept you back yes
we were we were represented really
nicely
yep I'm concerned I'm but you so many
iconic lines that like people it's felt
like it fit like camp but chanting like
yeah first of all like boys and boys and
girls and girls and welcome to New York
the place went on fire screaming so hard
she never made anybody less gay oh my
god Aaron room was dying sticks and
stones ever broke my bones
everyone was like it was literally like
color war yeah no that's a Bella cohort
like it literally turned into like this
just chant fast chant one two three
let's go [ __ ] one two three let's go
[ __ ] oh my god my crosshairs that I got
the most epic video of it and I
ex-addicts though trying to save it
like there's no nerve putting the X and
the save but like it's true where I'm
not trying to use the microwaves oh yes
they are
it happens to me all the time it's so
frustrating here and save is he no save
is here X is here there
the corner interesante snapchat has it
there's on the bottom and that's how it
should be
I'm sorry yeah so our box was so lit
also they had like a bunch of Amazon
celebs like the husband for marvelous
miss male he was also our box he like
looks exactly the same like he does on
TV and also this girl who's from Jessica
Jones not Christian rudder blonde girl
hi Trish
who's in the box sitting next me the
entire show I have never seen her face
before in my life they said she was on
jessica jones s jones but i don't know
her there's only one longer on Jessica
Jones she's a new show on Amazon she was
in our box to like I don't know how many
a Margo ended up like in the special box
because it was like a bunch of boxes I
saw Andy door from was bright about
refusing till I go to the bath and we
get a drink because I thought it was an
oversight yes it here yeah what else did
she thing she's saying love story shake
it off I knew you're trouble and she did
the I knew you were trouble tour version
so it's like you know what the bridge
she's like oh the saddest fear comes
creeping in I was so good like I was
really living like I was having a hard
time of bouncing like so many emotions
because like before ggot came the box I
was ready to be like nightmare like
literally throw myself off the terrace
like show my titties to the world but
then I'm like okay GG's here like I have
to like be a little bit cool but then I
was also like wanting to like dance and
jump and die and sweat but then also so
much and we just want it's like stare
and remember it uh-huh and also film it
so like I was really balancing all these
emotions and then people like have been
tagging me in videos that I'm in the
background of and like I'm literally
just like this yeah she was just like
standing that she's like all in because
I'm not thinking about how like it was
such for me like I don't think I'll ever
have an experience like that again
because it was a full Taylor production
background singers fireworks
pyrotech like everything but in such an
intimate setting I can't think that
there were more than 300 people there No
yeah so it was so special and like being
so close to it that was just like trying
to remember it because I don't think
I'll ever get an opportunity Taylor
again and you know me I spend my life
savings on front-row seats for Taylor
like I don't mind like shelling out but
it is still different it's different
because she was playing like to me and I
just I was really just trying to like
live now I want to go home and watch the
full thing because I just need to see
myself in the background I'm so glad I
wore sparkles cuz I was really shining
no I want to go home because we also did
see from the side like I want to see her
face head-on
yes so pretty she's like so pretty oh
and like I just couldn't deal with her
finally wearing red lipstick again like
red red not the crimson red and she was
talking about how she got her starting
country and like I feel like she never
talks about country which was just like
a metaphor or like why was she talking
about it was how she got her night job
in country music
I don't why she's leaving in two love
story yeah whatever and she was just
like she never says country anymore like
the word country do you know any man
yeah so it just made me think like she's
back
yeah she's I be some country and she's
just back to like just like bright
bubbly great Taylor okay so I was
looking for stories today and I saw a
story that story that like during her
concert she shaded Scott and oh yeah so
and shake it off when there's the rap
and it's like and dude don't get out
about the liars and the dirty dirty
cheats of the world you and she just
really emphasized the liars and the
dirty dirty cheats of the crew literally
yelled at you like back to you could've
been getting down - yeah really she did
it was deadly intentional it was
intentional she was singing it and then
she just goes and yelling is the word
way to put it liars dirty dirty 2rl and
then she just goes back to being cute
and she's like this say like it was
completely intentional yeah anything it
was about that it was what else for sure
who else cheated her in the past week no
totally yeah it was just a really great
show and I was really excited to be
there and that's it ya know it was like
the greatest night of my life like I
literally got home and I just like sat
in my dress and my heels and my full
makeup and I just sat there like
watching my story just like smiling
yeah girl checks me she's like I'm so
emotional oh my god I'm so happy for you
guys oh say thank you to jackie vega she
for white her ticket of course I would
have never done that to you and then I
would have missed third I was so mad it
wasn't Third Eye Blind it was one I
blind one man singing it was so [ __ ]
weird and it was like just one of those
nights that's like so me where it's like
everything goes wrong bets in the food
at the restaurant I went to dinner and
like I was starving starving it was so
slow everything was just like so men we
could barely like get her it was just it
was coming so hard and if I if we had
had a great meal then we went to
she like concert and we just left it was
only in Gramercy like it wasn't a big
lift it would have been fine but it's
just like everything sucked everywhere
so terrible it's just so me you know
sorry like I should've learned we went
to Sarabeth's which is not a good dinner
Oh when mentally they went to Sarabeth's
I'm like what is he doing they serve
pancakes no but they have like tuna
tartare and everything but you were in
such a great area also Hill said
Gramercy Hotel has the best Italian
restaurant in lobby
well we [ __ ] up like I believe been
for that in charge of reservations and I
was happy to go to barboonia and then he
was love for Berlin actually barboonia
sucks Mike no he'll soon you can't get a
reservation an hour before sure sure
sure
whatever that was I blame men for that I
apologize
I was like in charge of the food oh well
skeet Oh Susan so anyways the concert
was just it wasn't a concert it was just
like a man and his good man his guitar
which I knew it would be but I thought
they would be like and I kind of
associated like Third Eye Blind with
blink-182 so if like one member of
blink-182 was playing acoustic blink-182
songs like that's kind of cool
yeah but I guess I heard I blind is not
blink 2031 has two beggars jumper and
semi charmed kind of life but then also
this guy was singing just random songs
and no one was singing along so I don't
think there bear even Third Eye Blind
songs I think it was just like songs he
wrote like on his own sad it was so
[ __ ] weird yeah I'm sorry I I just
remembered that we saw a duel Eva and
out yeah in the booth yes cute yeah I
think they're cute I mean I have like
the most respect for do it but I think
she doesn't I also the most respect for
her back muscles yes Michael I was
getting slightly right I don't even know
Jackie she was wearing that like furry
tube top and black that you wanted yeah
that I have oh yeah yeah I'm wearing it
it is so pretty finally fit that's so
good nice cool I got it I didn't fit I
thought I got their own size and then I
lost a few pounds you know it's good I
never had I'd never happened I thought I
might build was just like two buildings
yeah speaking of Vegas tomorrow we're
leaving for Vegas and there is no show
but tomorrow is also the last day that
our merch store is open so head to shop
morning toast calm and know a lot of you
get paid tomorrow so we left it up until
longer than usual till tomorrow so
everyone can get their stuff there's new
summer items like koozies hats fanny
packs towels flags then also all the
best sellers are back in stock so the
sorority sweatshirts which are selling
like hotcakes
the pop sockets but the tostones
selenite all right yeah just look into
the data that's being sold I said I
checked two different koozies had number
one in two spots oh really because left
him I checked it was a sorority
structure and the first time I checked
you miss the pop sockets wow the jewel
skin is there to the decal we don't
enjoy shearling but if you do jewel and
it helps you feel free together toasty
sticker just lots of good stuff that
won't be back ever so shop morning toast
calm for another 36 hours yeah and then
we got to close it cuz you gotta get
your orders out right anything else we
need to recap no I feel ship rows coming
on the show today
oh yeah that's so exciting last night I
went to watch southern charm and I
actually wound up watching season 1
episode 1 Wow and I was kind of into it
because I kind of talked about this
week's episode actually I can't say
didn't watch it but I want to talk about
southern charm of the whole because
we've come really far and when you
watched the first episode it's so
[ __ ] creepy because of the Thomas and
the JD at all and I want to talk to him
about oh there's so many things I need
to talk to chef about like I need to
talk to him at his podcast we're gonna
have a song I need to talk to him about
just like being a man about town like
what goes on in Charles - like it's such
a small town he's now like this major
[ __ ] he just went golfing with are you
David like I need to know more yeah you
know he's like a megastar
I would say he's maybe one of the most
successful Bravo liberties like one of
the most popular yeah
consistently he's having a rough season
yes and I did speak and oh I was once
talking about Jack some pretty sweaty
cuz I spoke about that with him um and
he loved to say okay good I'm looking
forward to it also um
while you guys were at Taylor Swift last
night I was at a Taylor Swift first
Ariana gotten a SoulCycle you know what
and that liked it I actually would have
went to that if I didn't have to like to
have my hair yeah it was incredible it
was had 54th with a Nicholas who does
musical money so like he's just in tune
as hell what if I okay on the Taylor and
he played some really interesting
choices
he played Whitehorse at one point was
just I was full-body chills oh my god
wow what a song wow I'm like so upset
when's the next one
um I think on Wednesday see just some
good verses cuz I think the week before
he did Taylor no Rihanna again but he
played a lot of 1989 like playing space
what I'm trying to think like I can't
even remember it was just like so did he
play side to side no when I thought he
was it's like a song he played Thank You
max he played um No
yourself to cry he played break up with
your boyfriend girlfriend girlfriend he
played one Ari song that I didn't that
I'm not so into um it just went by so
quickly that's the best I was hardly
paying attention to the songs I didn't
even notice them because they were
unless they were like cuz Whitehorse was
like an interesting choice what other
Taylor so yeah yeah weak [ __ ] um and
there were a lot it was a very toasty
class so if anyone was there please
comment um Frank he play romantics no he
played you need to come down for the
stretch but he didn't that was the only
new song that he played okay if it comes
to you I feel like I'm missing a whole
album in my cousin's red city I know
fearless Red Mountain okay whatever
reputation oh um I did something bad he
started it and it was so good I love
rock you do that every time I like
really would go to that even though now
that you're talking about it those are
out of songs like talk to her for me and
I realize like I'm not like an Oreo and
I like Queen I would rather do like
Taylor strippers Lady Gaga I mean you
take what you can get and but the Ariana
songs were gonna like thank you next was
incredible yeah and I love new to
yourself to cry me too that's awesome
one last time you play oh it's just
that's a great so I agree I don't cycle
to that yeah I thought you've a place I
decided or cycle spin I'm looking grab I
try to use a microwave but without
further ado I do feel as though it's
time because it's been 20 minutes and we
have a guest today oh yeah we should so
it definitely feels like it's time it's
almost past it but it's time to deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast know we can
but I would be remiss if I do you know
that I'm packing for Vegas which is so
pertinent because today's episode is
brought to you by liquid IV and I did
literally pack so much like what IV
because it is the most important thing
on my packing looks like I don't even
need to clean underwear I just need
liquid IV because it's the fastest most
efficient way to stay hydrated trying to
drink more water liquid IV hydrates you
two to three times faster and more
efficiently than water alone with an
added bonus and vitamin C b3 b5 b6 and
b12
it's the fastest-growing wellness brand
you can find them everywhere even Costco
you can find their hydration multiplier
sold at all Cosco's nationwide their
products utilize cellular transport
technology a specific ratio of glucose
sodium and potassium
when mixed with water and helps your
body absorb more of the water in
nutrients that you
drink directly into your bloodstream so
obviously for hangovers this is a
no-brainer it has worked countless times
for all of us it is truly a saving grace
and maybe the only thing that can get me
through this trip to Vegas we love
liquid IV and we know you will too
right now our our listeners are getting
25% off at liquid I be calm when you use
our code toast at checkout that's a 25%
off anything you order on liquid IVs
website so go to liquid I be calm and
enter promo code totes to get your
savings and start getting better
hydration that's liquid I be calm promo
code toast don't wait to start properly
hydrating today
he also played you belong with me and I
was all dead on the floor singing Marcos
regime yeah but you know what I just
thought of something this morning Jackie
because like so funny yesterday was my
birthday and I showed up here looking
like an actual piece of trash today like
means nothing and I literally never
looked more beautiful tan or thinning my
life chat maybe it's for chef but you
know we used to take like those selfies
or sometimes we take pictures we should
take them before the show because what
we see them after the show but after the
show I'm exhausted I have no color left
on my face we've been through this
before when we take them before the show
our faces are like so tired that's when
we take them after the show we've
exercised all of our muscles we're ready
to smile but like you know just a
thought okay let's get into it because
our first story is the world's
highest-paid entertainers of 2019 list
is here from Forbes are you ready for it
so no pun intended number one highest
paid celebrity of 2019 is Taylor Swift
obviously number two we have Kylie
Jenner number three Kanye West number
four Lionel Messi number five and
Sheeran six Cristiano Ronaldo seven
Neymar eight the Eagles nine dr. Phil
McGraw ten Canelo Alvarez dr. Phil that
is so interesting it is interesting
especially because all the top ten is
really comprised of so many different
types of celebrities like reality star
musician athlete band like there's so
many different different types of celebs
that I find it so interesting that not
one category like dominated the top ten
like everything maybe all the athletes
would be at the top or the musicians
yeah right that's what we Kylie so
impressive right but like dr. Phil makes
I'm sorry
Eagles are actually the yes shocking dr.
Phil isn't shocking to me when I found
out that Judge Judy is a highest-paid
woman on television per episode she's
making like 52 million dollars a year
like good for her
set didn't shock me because dr. Phil
literally never stops working his TV
show radio show he's a podcast now and
he's so well-respected in this field you
just literally says no to nothing
I'm the Eagles it's quite shocking what
is the Eagles band
Marga a team I'm dead you google what
they sing Margaret forgot I get them
computes which with like the police the
who there's a lot of them and then when
I think of the police I always think of
that episode of friends but it's a
number 15 is Dwayne Johnson so like dr.
Phil is making more money than Johnson
is a cell number 20 is jay-z dr. Phil is
making more money though geez foggy is
making more than jay-z that's Chuck King
Hotel California oh really
I always think that William Hung sang
that song really yeah the guy from
American Idol yeah I know em you guys my
god
number 23 medians how is that a joke oh
I didn't I really thought you were
serious cuz maybe he performed in that
American night he did that's memories he
never made it through oh my god I can't
William Hung sang that song on American
Idol out of side dish in and it was like
so bad everyone was dying and it went
totally viral that was like the first
song he was singing yes I don't think it
was I I actually think it was like Ricky
Martin well me too like she bangs she
wasn't it she way google it
I'm right so William American Idol
audition think I'm right I think I'm
right I don't I don't know if I'm right
but I just
pretty sure it's not Hotel California
okay wait no William Hung American Idol
audition I know I'm here I'm here but
like I haven't listened to it so okay so
we'll continue
Alex saying that you're right she's yeah
but I would okay you know that siragugal
Margo okay I'm sorry if three people
actually thought she made like a
highly-respected but why don't you
google it everyone's saying it was she
bangs [ __ ] yeah he was like yep right
here Ricky Martin really among she bangs
okay so now I understand why you
my job okay cuz it was wrong factually
incorrect okay so I'm glad that we all
figured it out and he only had one on
his right so he's a one-hit wonder he
went on but he's a Lucas mom that's a
different song yeah he was wondering
whether okay some other notable celebs
number 20 Beyonce number 22 Ellen they
left how number 21 it might have been a
tie for 20th maybe let me go back I was
20 and 20 are jay-z and Beyonce oh they
tied Opie's are married but I'll get
their income and then they probably
split it in half
Forbes yeah I mean I find that like I
find that to be very low like on the
list for them especially because they
only media property so it's not like
they're always it like title that would
be like Steve Jobs and reckoning number
20 rock nation mm-hmm I feel like Title
II was title is not successful but they
but they're pretending like it no but
what she's saying is that they have so
many other business interests other than
music that would really probably put
them way above Kanye yeah yeah Kylie but
no but not because Kanye has easy and
Kylie has kind of cosmetic surgery
sacani on the cover of Forbes yes I'm
gonna get to that that's for this issue
so we had 26 is Kim Rihanna is 36 Travis
Scott is 39 row good for him Wow
rocky get out of jail yet but this is
like so crazy Scarlett Johansson is
number 47 like that makes Marvel because
of Margo yeah okay in that comic book
men naked like into the plus-size Jewish
comic world yeah because I need some
Marvel or like DC Comics money because
that is the money that is money like I'm
really happy for sophie turner because
she's in it out yes Dark Phoenix she
will be why is she here like so some of
this like it makes sense when you look
at it but then it's like okay how is
Scarlett Johansson making more than
sophie Turner who also did Game of
Thrones this year Game of Thrones
because it was if you think about it was
a little like eight episodes and let's
say she made a million episode they
didn't really know I said like Emilia
Clarke that that realm was like 500
grand right so she was probably like
just a little bit less and this is like
her first Dark Phoenix movies so
probably didn't get paid as much as
college it should be there soon yeah she
will be on this list in five years yeah
judge Judy's 59
and then Steve Harvey 69 so dr. Phil's
making way more than Steve Harvey but
and super Harvey worked so much harder
he does everything he literary system
exactly feel justice dr. Cullen I think
he has a podcast Steve Harvey hosts like
four different shows interesting and he
is a radio show a daytime talk show
mm-hmm interest something does all the
things that dr. Phil does and then so
much more and ariana grande is 62 which
is so crazy it is but you were the one
who told me that like when you make me
take it literally takes a year for you
to get that music so Taylor's got the
money for writing songs so Taylor is now
in 2019 where reputation came out in
2018 and now she's the highest I think
that makes sense
whereas maybe next year ariana grande
will be much higher on the list because
this year was her year of music yes yes
I I hope that is the case because Taylor
didn't happen she was so quiet all year
so for her to be number one is it has to
be residual right no it takes like you
know net 60 payday I'm ready for Kylie
to be number one on this list I just
think like that would be so epic and
they would really be like an accurate
representation of our culture do you
know what I mean like she really is so
like 2019 yeah and she's so in like
she's like a representative of like what
Instagram reality TV influencing can do
right but like for her to be the
highest-paid celebrity of all the other
[ __ ] out here doing it doing it the
corporate way yeah would be Wow and like
with quote unquote talent right like
with a skill yeah
with a trade okay and Kanye is on the
cover of Forbes under Kanye's hood a
rare peek inside the kinetic chaotic
creative mind behind a billion-dollar
sneaker Empire so Kim posted his cover
and wrote the sweetest caption Kanye and
the cover of Forbes
soin crowd so incredibly proud of my
husband I watched every day how hard he
works and how much of his heart and soul
he puts into his business every idea and
product that he creates it's of no
surprise to anyone who works with or is
close to Kanye that he has been able to
turn millions of dollars in debt into a
billion-dollar empire in only four years
a hundred percent on his own terms while
owning 100 percent of his business he
inspires me every single day and I'm so
happy that he is finally getting the
recognition and credit that he deserves
that is so impressive and I'm so glad
that this came out cuz I feel like ever
since Kanye went on that crazy rant
where he was four million dollars in
debt and asking Mark Zuckerberg for
money on Twitter no one's taken him or
his business like that seriously
but he's just been like quietly with his
head down working hard and like now has
a billion-dollar business that's the
second one in the family yeah I feel
like also when he talks about his
success people always go back to you
he's broke right you know how successful
can he be but in the words of Jewry
Kemsley every businessman at one point
in of another has been bankrupt yeah so
like this is what jury should throw in
Camille's face it's also like this was
only four years ago even though as a US
magazine is reporting that PK enter its
accounts have been frozen as their
failed to pay back what would two
million dollar loan I really don't want
to hear that no I know if I mean the
facade that they have going to like keep
up because I love enjoying their like
extravagant privileged lifestyle right
because like the way that she spends the
money who knows how they procured it
it's like she I love watching her spend
it yeah and I love watching her like
glam and everything I can't I can't
finish and anyways I'm happy for Kanye
I'm happy for Kim yeah yeah the whole
family yeah truly so who do you think
the next billion-dollar business is
gonna come to Oh Kim I think the
shapewear like might be it for her even
though they don't have a dollar in sales
yeah I just I think Anthony that with
the KK Network good American no way good
American is very successful I know it is
but Khloe doesn't own all of it and they
see me like where it's at now it's I
don't know that it's gonna get much
bigger but it's pretty big it's yeah
it's really I think it's a successful
business but it's not you know so
quietly I really like like when you
watch Keeping Up with the Kardashians
like they're always talking about their
businesses like how hard they work and
like Khloe really does it like she just
gets her [ __ ] done and like she really I
don't think she owns and has her good
American pop socket right I hate that
pop socket I just look at logo I hate
the logo it looks like a corporate logo
like she went to some conference and got
corporate
I think Nordstrom owns a percentage of
it no but like it looks like see a like
it looks like like politics ya know it
really bothers me that pops sake it
looks like something I once got it CES
freemar or at Adweek yeah you know yeah
like maybe to make it any chatter Brent
I could go like something written out
like good American and like script like
whatever yeah just that pops like it
pisses me
because I once saw someone else I think
was Hannah and she had it on once and I
was like what is that yeah
or you can get it it's no morning shows
pop sock if it's no toaster in the wild
pop second and certainly not here's the
thing pugs certainly nos certainly not
um the questions are just regular days I
couldn't be happier or more proud of
them who she might be the next
billion-dollar business are you kidding
yeah even me oh she's kidding oh my god
like what do they make money it's a blog
affiliate links that's just it's
literally the saddest thing speaking of
affiliate links I'm gonna segue into our
NYX in semi influencer related story oh
wow this is so crazy
this story is so crazy I'm gonna read
the whole thing because I mean everyone
thought I need all hands on deck here
Amanda Seyfried slams influencer for
quote flaunting lifestyle amid criticism
over her body image and her privilege
Amanda Seyfried is speaking out about
the importance of social media
personalities using their influence
responsibly after something Navis Ariel
Charnas received backlash for
perpetuating an unrealistic body image
with a photo of her postpartum bikini
body safely posted a screenshot of a
comment left on Charnas photo by Amanda
say foods friend Sophie flack in which
flat called charm is out for not
acknowledging her wealth and privilege
that may have contributed to her bounce
back after childbirth the writer went on
to say that Charnas is glorifying an
unhealthy body image regardless of
whether it's her natural build or not
although say free said the influencer
has since blocked her and flack Seyfried
writes we have to be open to the
discussion surrounding what we're
promoting okay so basically amanda
seyfried friend left like uh it was a
well worded trolli comment like it i
think this is a comment okay so it says
one totally fine that you're privileged
and thin good for you i am two ish got
no probl sharing our thin privilege just
like I have a Prada bag so to you so
weird got no problem with either of
those things but you're here like
slamming her privilege I have a problem
okay but if you don't acknowledge how
your wealth made your work out such body
possible you're just perpetuating the
patriarchal totally unrealistic notion
that mothers should bounce back after
childbirth and impossibility for anyone
who can't afford ample child care which
is almost everyone in this country lacks
to unpack here I know so condescending
to honey child you are glorifying an
unhealthy body image I don't care if
it's quote natural don't even try that
[ __ ] with me
in a society that already fetishes the
adolescent female form young girls don't
need any more images of emaciated women
thank you very much
how is this not body shaming if you if
this is her natural bills
no no it's three is literally the
meanest comment ever and just because
she's using big words she thinks that
she's above being a troll but this is so
trolli and it's bullying and it's body
shaming and it's show me three I know
you're better than this why not use your
platform to encourage more women to be
ambitious with business women or say run
for office or maybe sheesh I don't know
do something to help the kids literally
dying in cages but what do I know you do
you so man athief reposted the
screenshot of that comment with her own
caption this is so weird like what is it
me to see free doing getting involved in
influencer drama and then referring to
re alternates as a semi influencer which
is probably the meanest thing that would
happen here because I follow her and I'm
she is so influential but she is the
textbook influencer she has a lot of
followers she has a clothing line she
has melts what businesses like she uses
affiliate like she's not an influencer
who is totally what's what is a man to
say free to semi influential about her
does she not have enough followers
she's so influential so like that's not
only is it shady it's just wrong like if
you wanna be taken seriously don't just
like nobody you want to be that but
seriously don't call someone honey child
no but that would be like someone saying
amanda seyfried is semi-famous no she
say no but so she's an up-and-coming
actress ya know she's an actress yeah
like you so like doesn't she have
something better to do you know she
doesn't like Jack Mamma Mia Mamma Mia 3
don't go write it
people like see like I don't know feel
some type of way about something and
feel like it's unbelievably important
for them to say something and I feel
like when I first saw this article
obviously I was like where who's the
influencer where whatever and you could
take them down to it yeah let's go
because obviously like influencers most
of the time you do the combo because
they're out of control
and this isn't lack like a worldly
self-awareness sometimes asleep and I'm
sure the argument can be made that Ariel
Ternes sometimes does but this saying it
no it said why this is like Lisa
Vanderpump why are we picking this to
like come for Arielle Charnas I mean I
know I've met her sisters and they're so
nice and they're so skinny like I
actually got a massage at so house miami
and i saw her mom in this spa so skinny
yet they are natural
so thin and like yes she probably has a
trainer and like a nanny to watch her
kids while she went to go work out but
like there are plenty of people I mean
like I technically yes I could get a
trainer and if I did it would do nothing
you know I have a change no right like
just because you like have some sort of
access to what to things that can help
you lose weight like doesn't mean you
couldn't lose weight no but their
argument is contradictory cuz I'm the
one here and they're saying it's her
natural build and so she shouldn't be
promoting it but on the other hand she's
saying that she should recognize her
wealth and privilege that has allowed
her to have this body but they're saying
that it's natural right so are the genes
the privilege or I don't know I know so
no but genes you're just one just born
rich like she like no she really is but
also like she's so so thin and you can
they're saying that she's emaciated and
she's too skinny so like yours you don't
like how she looks yet you're saying
she's privileged to look like that right
someone just made a great comment if her
caption was like look what I did you can
do it to motivate yourselves like
rubbing it she's all the comments she
put a picture of herself in a bikini she
was like I'm really proud of myself like
what is the problem yeah I don't know
like I just said and for her for Amanda
safer to use her arguably much bigger
platform to she mom shame body shame and
just like put on blast this like girl
who like works hard and just like wants
to like be an influencer like what did
you do in Amanda yeah it's so weird it's
so weird and like Amanda's friend to do
this like I get like I get her motives
like she's just like and she's obviously
like an angry woman
you know like who just like has an axe
to grind in some sort of way with
Arielle Charnas but like for medicine
free who's like a busy woman like an
actress like with a very fulfilled life
what are you doing and also like to post
it as an indeed post like yes all your
flow is nasty now yeah the second ball
that goes into your story like a normal
person you know just beefing yeah and
this is where you want to put your stake
in the ground like right this ain't it
no it's so weird and I saw in one of the
toasters good people we're talking about
and someone made a point like just
because you have access to trainers and
and chefs or you know healthier foods
like doesn't necessarily mean that
you're gonna be able to do it like look
at Rob Kardashian right so it still
takes hard work and it's like please
[ __ ] if I like was
and I had money for like a nanny a team
of people and I could go work out an
hour with my trainer and like we make
dances like [ __ ] you know I would be
doing that so like we're all just
jealous oh for sure
I just this was shocking to me yeah you
know so anyways it was no it's shocking
because it's so unbelievably odd and if
we're gonna come in like guns blazing
full steam ahead to take down an
influencer we're gonna need something
bigger we're gonna need something better
yeah
the same it says like this just ain't no
like not at all it's so it's so mean
yeah and it's it's bad like saying that
she doesn't look like like how do we
evolved past like judging other women
for like having nannies and working out
like I really thought in 2019 like after
all the [ __ ] we've been through like
we were past this right but apparently
I'm a deciphered some no it's so
nitpicky and there's yes and there's
nothing there just like unfollow her if
you don't like it like some people like
for me like I follow her because it's
aspirational as [ __ ] like when I am her
age I want to have two kids and a nanny
and I want to be skinny like you know
what like it's aspirational also her
saying that she doesn't like promote
women being business women whatever
she's arguably one of the most
entrepreneurial influences out there a
great influencers out there and I think
she's setting a really good example as
far as like working mom being a working
mom and doing it on your own she's super
wealthy she could have you know just
like had her kids and just taking
pictures of them and and never been
worse all you know like her life would
have been the same yeah I know she
continued her Nordstrom line is super
successful yeah but she's being a
businesswoman like what are we doing I
don't know it's so weird it's so weird I
am NOT here to judge anyone else's
lifestyle body or mommy techniques
because you know what I'm gonna be a mom
one day knock on wood may be happy to be
terrible no one's allowed to say
anything when I am okay ya know at its
core it is weird yeah it's all it is off
1111 make a wish I wish that we would
just live in a society where women can
just do what they want as mothers as
businesswomen and as athletes I wish we
could all get along like we used to in a
nice walk yeah like those are but it's
so simple even though I don't know what
school you went to because we were not
getting on in middle school we're
getting along worse in middle school but
then we were in high school right middle
school was wedding like every week
someone was on the outs and go like if
you're if you hadn't been on the outs
yet like your turn was [ __ ] bagging I
was on the outs first so I just gotten
kind of got to watch everyone else go
through on the outs last and it's not a
good place to me no I think I would
rather go mmm I think I'm gone in a
second just to see what it's like for
the first person yeah but like when it
happens to me first I didn't know what
was happening and that that it would
happen to everyone else you know right I
got just like it was just me it was just
a cycle of middle school life it's a
crazy thing that happened did that
happen to you guys - yes - have you ever
friends and at one point one of you is
always on the app we were three some
third girl she was the first to go
second girl she was second to go and
then they came for the Queen and I'll
literally never forget it as long as I
live and it's like killing me not to say
the girl's name I never spoke to her
again don't say it I'm not going to I
never I well I will literally never
forget it it changed me as women I mean
it made me into the monster that I am so
I'm so grateful because like who knows
maybe if I'd stayed friends with mm-hmm
that like she would have brought me down
and I never would have been a successful
morning show host or comedian oh that's
not funny right now I bet she's just
like you know trying to get tickets on
StubHub you tell her sis and [ __ ] is
blocking the transaction up in school
[ __ ] middle school man [ __ ] what
happened to you oh my god are you
kidding Margot was turning we were just
talking about our spare into so like you
know someone always gets turned on it's
like a new thing every week in middle
school oh whoa whoa I thought were just
talking about like that we were bullied
in middle school I think it's because we
were saying the quote from Mean Girls
why can we get along like these two
middle school but we're like actually
middle school sucked ass sucked at one
point like someone is always on the outs
I went first in my group of friends
Claudia went last which is the worst
place um well I started out as the new
girl so it was rough that was always in
and out because people were like
intended to like me to be mean and
probably my favorite fact about tended
to like her to be mean cause I also wore
dresses like probably my favorite fact
about Margo is that our parents got
divorced
I mean moved to a new school new city it
was a really tough transition me and
Margaret were in middle school together
the first day at a new school Margo's in
the fifth grade first day what happened
she
that's your period no sixth-grade know
what I got it I got it I got it in the
6th grade I remember the date I got it
in the 6th grade when did you get yours
in the 7th grade right before soccer
practice nice I got mine in the 8th
grade right before lunch
Wow late I got mine on the I got mine at
a house from Oriental I got mine in this
which is so idea like I was home from
school changing for soccer practice and
I got it like right between like God
knew I couldn't handle getting in a
public setting oh that's nice I got mine
in school but mom happened to be in
school that day so like spooky weird I
got my cam home from orientation with
mom and I was just like I think and
she's like what like in some way I don't
think there's anything more painful than
like getting your period I'm like
talking about it
you know don't know what it feels like
so you don't know and it's brown so
you're confused ok we got to keep we got
to keep checking along Wow ok someone
wrote in the in the live stream that
they got their period in the 10th grade
Wow Nicole Connors as a junior she was
eating wisely late bloomer like wild
yeah interesting so interesting ok third
story only Jessica samsaris who's
Jessica samsaris does the Simpson is
coming out with a memoir now a birthday
Jam supposed to yesterday and Erika
Jayne I'm in such great company and
Wendy Williams ooh that will detail her
marriage to Nick Lachey Jessica Simpson
is ready to tell all in a memoir slated
to be released in 2022 booties quote I
will be releasing my first book on
February 4th with HarperCollins the pop
star turned designer posted on Instagram
Wednesday I've been working so hard on
and I have opened my heart up in a way
I've never before and now I can't wait
to share it with the world the untitled
book will profile her life as a pop star
reality star ahead of a fashion empire
and a mother this is interested and I
feel like she has a lot to say I think
she thought to say but I also think she
is such an interesting like career how
like she was like at the world's biggest
pop star and then like fell out of out
of it and somehow managed to still be a
billionaire through her Kmart line like
I like bought some of her stuff a pair
of wedges and a beach
no and it's good [ __ ] I just think like
the transition from pop star reality
star Z Lister to Z Lister but with a
billion dollars it's really interesting
Brittany Lister yeah with like a great
husband and great family yeah great tits
and you know Diana Ross has her
stepmother in law oh yes yeah what is it
her sister is married to Diana Ross's
son that's pretty close yeah so her know
your sisters mother-in-law yeah it's
hurt they're her in-laws oh no they're
athletes
no but the Simpsons in-laws are the
Rosses yeah but whatever still counts
still counts this is great I think I
actually might read them they may be
just I've always had this like kinship
with Jessica Simpson ever since like the
daisy dukes days because she and I had
the same birthday and I've like felt
this connection to her um so I'm really
I'm just happy for her like she's a
celebrity like I think I'll always like
yeah yeah and I'm not problematic I
think also she has a really fun
personality like I feel like she could
be like shady and funny and that this
book could be shady and sunny I mean I
just need to know more about the Nick
Lachey of it all I know but I feel like
the weirdness was on there like wasn't
Nick Lachey wasn't weird like the
Simpsons were weird the the Joseph is a
Joseph yeah he's my Lohan so when it
comes to these matters I kind of want to
hear from Michael che yeah and Nick
Lachey just like rebounded with the girl
of his dreams like what does that happen
no and like they couldn't be happier
married longer thriving yeah people get
more a healthy of a lifestyle no never
happens
never never with the with the rebound
yeah it's just supposed to be a
one-night stand you know no but the same
thing I mean Jessica wasn't her rebound
wasn't her husband now but like now
Jessica's in the same type of
relationship that's like healthy it's
stable yeah can withstand the test of
time
so maybe like their situation really set
them up there's a successful future true
can't wait to read more about it me too
okay next story more about Instagram
influencers Instagram influencers are
flocking to a toxic bright blue lake as
government warns to stay away this is so
so easy
I can't the beautiful blue waters of the
man-made pond honestly the water is so
beautiful mister I thought it was Jackie
O Flo what's it called um it is called I
was gonna go the novosibirsk
Maldives are actually caused by a nearby
coal plant okay
is Chernobyl gibes hotel government
officials are warning tourists away from
traveling to the Novosibirsk Maldives a
lake that looks natural beautiful but is
actually man-made and potentially
dangerous the body of water is located
near the Russian city of Novosibirsk and
received its nickname for its bright
blue water which is reminiscent of the
Maldives a group oh it's not in the
Mahdi's they call it that because it
looks like trying to find a picture of
it they can't figure out how this
validates a bird with islands that are a
popular luxury vacation destination in
the Indian Ocean the Maldives are not
this the site has been increasing in
popularity with Instagram users who
flocked to the area to snap the photo
with the otherworldly huo the Siberian
pond even has its own Instagram count
which shows visitors posing the other
water that they're like encouraging it
well no but like not the governor
fischels claim the water's incredible
blue colour is actually the result of a
massive ash jump from a nearby coal
plant and are asking visitors to stay
clear of the area though this lake is
not a natural miracle at all but an ash
dump in which the sewage PP is like
having its own Instagram account
influencing is is great I don't know if
it's a lake that had someone made an
Instagram account for the lake but if
the government really does what I know
it's beautiful it's beautiful but like
it's like waste around it's like too
blue I wouldn't jump in that you know
some yellow tape yeah whatever you say
it's not technically poisonous but they
should not go swimming in the body water
yeah you shouldn't go swimming in a body
of ash I imagine yeah I feel as though
it would probably be rather painful
that's crazy
cuz look at this you think you're like
to know that this is in Russia like
something a right no that totally looks
like Maldives are like Jamaica yeah Wow
interest on so you guys were planning a
trip there maybe reconsider yeah
Chernobyl vibes for sure Chernobyl vibes
okay fifth and final story some food
news oh I love some food news because I
feel as though we're one of the leading
sources on what's going on with them the
impossible foods industry we definitely
are and now impossible foods is
developing fake seafood for vegetarians
fishless fish the plant-based company
hopes to offer a replacement for every
animal-based food by 2035 impossible
foods is coming cooking up something
sure to make even more of a splash and
the stay
then they're impossible burger a fish
product totally free of fish the
California company known for whipping up
patties made entirely of plants has its
sights set on doing the same for seafood
according to New York Times the only way
we concede is to make fish from plants
that is more delicious than the fish
that stretch that strip mined from the
ocean
The Times reports that the impossible
BIRT Foods has been working on
developing alternatives to fish and
other seafood food plant-based recipes
or by growing cells and laboratories to
recreate the seafood flavor Brown said
the company uses heme a protein also
seen in their meat formula okay so I
face like cool sure whatever but then
what do you think about it's like no one
eats fish because they like it
no one this is a total opposite it's
like no on its face it's like a like
chemical made fish like they just stinky
enough now we're gonna add plants but
then it's like damn if they can really
do it like that nobody thought they
could do the impossible burger because
they thought it was impossible but they
did it like I have a feeling they
actually are gonna do it and I kill it
and then like maybe in a hundred years
like we could live in a world like where
we don't kill animals well that I think
the environmental impact of this is
super cool because it's like I once took
an oceanography class and just you know
the rates devastating we're we're
fishing fish and they were talking about
how the UM what was the name of the fish
the tooth fish that they were like the
to fish off the shores of Patagonia like
we're depleting it there and because
everyone loves to eat it and I was like
who eats to fish I've never even heard
of it it turns out it's sea bass I'm the
tooth [ __ ] connoisseur so I didn't take
an oceanography class but I did one time
going out with Leonardo DiCaprio and he
told me that in you know in Asia right
now there is now 90% less fish and ocean
than there was 100 years ago and I told
you I said Leo that's fascinating thank
you it is fascinating and I'll just I'll
never cease to bring up an opportunity
where I can tell everyone that I was on
a boat with Leonardo DiCaprio and you
were learning like you were right I mean
I showed up in the boat like with
champagne and like right at a party and
it was more of like a whale watching
experience just like Leo's very tempered
but I still I had a great time and I
learned a lot clearly so for that reason
I'm here for this but when I think about
fish I only eat it because it's healthy
and it's good for me but I don't want to
be eating it because I'll sneak however
like I could go for like some impossible
mussels because I can't like if it's
shellfish actually might be down
right right salmon pasta cheerio do you
think they'll make it impossible
whatever sauce probably I think they
have to whoever told the whatever story
on the show do you want us to embarrass
you or not we're not okay
we all were out to lunch like a really
long time ago before we kept kosher this
was around the same time it was so Moody
and like you were really like in it it
was like the puberty like you were a
[ __ ] like really it was a tough time as
a family yeah like like right like it
was after post-divorce post daddy dying
like we were all we were not like the
healthy individuals we work today yeah
we're definitely like oh not okay scenes
we were like we were moody teenagers and
we were out to lunch in Margaret ordered
the mussels I'm like the waitress was
standing behind her was just in one of
her [ __ ] prepubescent itchy ass moods
and Margo ordered the muscle she's like
all of the muscles and she was like very
dismissive like like whipping her head
almost and she like handed the menu and
Margo thought she was done ordering and
Marta lady was like well what kind of
sauce do you want you want like I'll
just have a like way to whatever
whatever sauce and we're like what you
say that gonna take whatever sauce you
got but she said well honey than
whatever sauce imma ride there's no such
thing like it was one of those things
where like it could have been it could
have been like a small thing that we
just let go then literally to this day
we still order clams with whatever size
yeah yeah messes with every size so I
think if impossible foods it's gonna
make muscles its key that they make
whatever is impossible whatever only a
person who knows what's in the whatever
sauce is this age you should bottle your
own sauce he's perfect for muscles and
whatever's and calls the whatever sauce
I have any muscles and years I don't
even know what pairs with it anymore
yeah oh my god that's such a good I know
you or just make a sauce that you like
yeah I wouldn't like mussels or clams
one cuz they're not gonna sure to
because I just so smelly like I need a
whip at my sin bird every time like
spritz the table after I'm done eating
my fingers it's not for me um I underst
and that but at least you have a semper
to get you through it yes
Sen Bert is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes a way for you to discover new
perfumes without buying an entire bottle
more than 450 designer brands for you to
choose a perfume and a cologne from each
month you choose a perfume you want to
try and they'll send you a 30 day supply
it's so great because I'm not the type
of person who has like one fragrance I
just more like to like try fancy ones
and people to ask and I'm like oh it's
Giorgio Armani you know I meet booger
yeah yes I had to learn how to pronounce
it maybe your vulgar E if you're not
sure what type of scent you're looking
for you can sort through the website and
find your new fragrance by brand style
occasions season and more you can check
out user ratings and reviews on any
fragrance and with our exclusive offer
for our listeners you can get 50% off
your first month today at scent bird
dot-com slash toast that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
fragrance go to Sanford dot-com slash
toast and sign up for 50% off your first
month again that's scen t-bird comm
slash toast for you to try your first
perfume or cologne for seven dollars and
fifty cents sign on smell amazing
I love Sanford I gotta pack them up for
this trip because we are not checking
August which is why Sanford and that
pertinent Day party like sweat is real
and I'm definitely gonna need some
parfum ya snitch just air-dropped me
something bread and Charlie supposed to
that nine minutes Grandin Charnas
Ariel's husband posted a skinny person
is it her it's her it's a TV T and said
TV t in honor of my upcoming birthday
warning this body is not attainable
please do not attempt to attain such a
body by working out if you attempt to
attain you must have at least three 90s
and B shirt can only pay them in cash
but also and thank you shout outs on
Instagram every time such body is posted
if you can't afford a nanny please do
not attempt to have a very successful
career in order to do so genetics may or
may not have played a factor
only HS 30 and older allowed to view
this post use must be accompanied by a
therapist
please note such warnings have been
provided for in compliance with the
American body-shaming Association damn
he snapped
damn he's had at first I was like what
is what is he doing as a girl what is
you doing but they by the end I'm like
this is hilarious yeah it's a little
thirsty no it's a little out of touch um
I think it's a boy know what they're
saying what they were saying it's like
when you post something like this
like you should acknowledge the fact
that you're privileged you need this
disclaimer so here's the disclaimer if
Arielle Charnas won suppose the picture
everybody I wish they would only give it
so much clout because it's so stupid
yeah I'm saying that usually but when
someone bigger there's a bigger platform
is doing it sometimes when a troll like
she also post a lot of troll comments
works like we would never see them
because there's limited motor powers but
a ministy Fergie's a more famous than
her so like she's not giving her a
platform sure has it that's true so
honestly I was ready to not be here for
that kook post but I am here for it and
I'm also here for Shep rose he is
actually in the building we're gonna
take a brief pause if you have any
questions for Shep rose about something
charmer that is new podcasts about is he
dating I don't know leave the comment on
the YouTube stream we'll do our absolute
best together Tim go get a snack go to
the bathroom talk to Sally eith
watercolor we will be back in two
minutes
thank you so much for your patience I
will see you in a bit
you
we are back with amis man of mystery
chef rose southern charm Shep rose
he brought a half drinking bottle of
wine and wouldn't tell us why until we
went live so without further ado I am
the least mysterious person mysterious
about this okay I had a great great date
last night
I won that I was looking forward to and
we had been texting them and then we
finally went on a debate and it was
great we had a fun time and the
conversation was good we went to a
champagne bar it was called like
something champagne Ares champagne I
said went and below is a sake bar so we
went like downstairs at sake she was fun
remember I was telling you in the we're
at the wedding yes well no but I've told
I told you that a lot of girls I've been
meeting lately are they're like
beautiful but they're not all that fun
mm-hmm she was fun and beautiful it's
hard to find beautiful and fun girls
yeah that's right yes the bottle so we
went back to hotel had a got a bottom
bottle of wine and she's like I'm gonna
go home I was like yeah that's a good
idea and little kiss and I had a half
bottle of wine from the restaurant yeah
and I took it upstairs I was I'm not
gonna drink a bottle of wine by myself
and I wasn't gonna leave it there
because it was a fairly expensive wine
so this is mine is this even a gift
remember a ssin of my good day you get
married score it out for the horse okay
this is so sweet oh I'm so excited about
this thank you so much do you have some
sure but no I want to keep it
oh well keep the team no no mrs. special
you're gonna keep this bottle or ever
can be aged like a fine
oh you can't you I'm gonna work it I'm
gonna spend some money you know women
taking elders pressure so we're sitting
here now with fellow podcast host
Shepherds you recently launched a
podcast do you feel different you feel
like Jam rather
I'd rather not know I I did this podcast
I was kind of talked into it by my
friends at William Morris and now
they're trying to get me to write a book
like you and I don't I'm like
overwhelmed a little bit like I sort of
pride in myself on not having to do
anything earlier you are the eternal
child yes I am and now I have a like I
given myself work and but I enjoy it and
I'm working on some things and I'm going
to LA in a week or actually a few days I
go to Tahoe today and I'll be in LA and
it's easy in LA to do podcasts right
because everybody is trying to like get
their name out yeah he has a podcast
yeah yeah and so but in Charleston it's
not so easy I know like there's there's
not a whole lot of people that are
trying to get out there and like people
are in the entertainment business or
what have you so I'm gonna have to be
creative do you not want to have your
cast mates on the show I got a big
trouble for that yeah yeah I should
probably not have you know as much as I
would I originally when I said I was
like I don't want to talk about reality
TV and southern charm but obviously
that's the red meat that the listeners
maybe want to do but I can get in
trouble because there's like a line I
guess you can cross pretty easily yeah
so I just leave it at that maybe but so
I have all these different interesting
people I want to have on but I'm just
not good at asking people favors so like
hey come on in order to be a successful
podcast oh so you have to be comfortable
like being thirsty and I feel like
you're a lot of things but you ain't
thirsty no I'm not but I'm gonna try
it's hard yeah and if you know I'm born
with that thirst gene I know my my
parents friends used to be like you
would be great at sales I was like no I
wouldn't you know I hate it I don't want
to bother anybody so it's cool though I
think somebody sent me a 25 thousand
people listened is that good yes okay
where's my check so
now we have so much in common because
we're both podcast shows and we're also
both dog parents cuz you just got a dog
okay little crazy named him lil Craig oh
yes and so lest anybody worry about my
travels and John surround the earth um I
have a I'm a co-parent one of my best
friends Tony we're Co pairs were
straight two men who are Co parents of a
progressive and I got my friend to make
a meme and I think it's hilarious oh
yeah a show called my two dads way back
in the day it Paul Reiser and this other
guy they raised this little girl it's
like three men and a little baby right
so cute so I'm gonna post that later and
let the people out no I am NOT
neglecting this dog fully committed I
get that I get that tail because I
travel so much but Theo has many family
it takes a village it truly does do you
think that this is like a step for you
in the right direction of like maybe you
know having a child one day yes see I
think so and I was talking to my lovely
date last night and I mean I was maybe
trying to appease any fears of my
immaturity but I was like yeah I got
this dog because I'm always like trying
to improve myself I hate to use a dog as
like a tool to myself but I think that
that's the ballet
it changes you yeah of course is you to
like get up and do those things for Bach
correct and so I'm baby steps right and
so and the name Craig doesn't mind truly
Craig loves it correct thinks of human
Craig yeah you a good big Craig you
italeri yeah so big Craig thinks it's
cute that you named the dog yeah he
likes it he thinks it's an honor I to me
it's like a little bit of a homage and a
little bit of it yeah yeah but I love
jabbing Craig and that's what I do and
that's how our relationship works well
we got a lot of questions for you about
like where the line is when it comes to
Craig cuz you guys definitely have this
like brotherly fraternal relationship
where you put fun at each other but you
ever feel like you take you too far
especially on the show no well yes we've
gotten in what we got in a huge fight in
the Bahamas
and I threw a plate with a stake in the
front of waste away yeah yeah but he's a
fragile guy I think I know where the
line is but he begs for it he honestly
like so for example on our trip on our
RV trip that was rough
no it wasn't it was so much fun and let
me tell you why I gave him a hard time
two reasons one is he almost put a metal
bowl with food into a microwave in our
RV essentially setting it on fire and
maybe exploding and killing us all right
also we stopped it like an Applebee's
with like and I mean wasn't on camera
but just to get food for everybody and
he sat down and his passport fell out of
his pocket in an Applebee's we didn't
realize it till two hours later
whoo thank God the whole app movie staff
looking for a passport would you go back
yeah okay I make fun of you if you do
say the password 1,000% and I mean he's
just he's absurd I love him but he I
love absurd people you know eccentric
absurd people but boy does he beg for it
yeah he doesn't make his case super but
he doesn't need a case he just be
yourself one thing I said about Craig
that I think he's sort of changed for
the better in the and that all the
seasons we've done is that in the be
remember if you remember the first few
seasons he can kind of didn't own his
absurdity yeah you know like he was
making excuses and lies and this and
that he's starting to own it yes he's
like I'm crazy
yeah I'm hi I'm Craig and I'm kind of
crazy I'm like that that's a big step
for him well I actually happened to
watch season 1 episode 1 last night
because I guess it was on Bravo and it
recorded on my television that's what
and it was so interesting to watch one
because everyone is really so that the
show is really the same like the core
cast is the same aside from like Thomas
but I'm wondering who do you think has
changed the most I mean III disagree
first of all the guy like the cast is
not the same I mean yeah
like you and Dragan Cameron that's the
og he doesn't want to do it he honestly
does not like his relationship with the
show is so on and so on and you know I
took a break from southern charm and
Jackie was always like it's about
shutting up about you guys watching and
I'm fully back in this way and there's
one thing that nobody talks about that
bothers me a lot that I need to get your
perspective on then like why does nobody
talk about how incredibly odd it is that
Patricia who is like this established
older woman it's like out hanging out
with 30 year olds well here's my I mean
I love Patricia but I mean Patricia is a
widow right and she I mean she hangs out
with the butler a lot she she correct
means rightly so like wants to be you
know some action in her life I think the
show itself is been really cathartic in
a good way for her I think she loves
interacting with the fans I think it's
like giving her like I don't think she
was ever like and had any health did she
but it's given her like a second wind
she gets really in the weeds on the
drama like on the one hand she's
dressing Ashlee and then the other hand
she's like on her Instagram lives
talking sometimes she backs the wrong
horses
yes seen this before so finally she's on
the right side of history and so I'm
coming around to her she isn't oh oh
well because you and her are butting
heads she's firmly on team Madison well
yeah Madison's cut her hair for ten
years and you are firmly like not auntie
Madison and I can't understand your
reasoning why and I'm sure everyone in
the world has yelled you about this like
comparing um Austin having a threesome
and then like heard like revenge
cheating on him is like so more than
revenge cheating though so she revenge
cheated okay maybe there even though
then she did she got someone to DM
change Agentry and like and then denied
it but then like
owned it and then denied it again then
she sent text messages screenshot of
text message to Austin talking [ __ ] oh
you said that before all this happened
before you knew about the chantry thing
you said what she did is so much worse
than what Austin did so I'm just like
well that's how I feel like okay okay
your your significant other cheats on
you you talk about it you decide to stay
together yes that doesn't I think it is
totally shows no class I'd be like I'm
gonna get you I'm great like if you want
to break up and you want to see
people do that and I'll support you you
know but it's not like a tit-for-tat
that's just to me that's not acceptable
or Austin and Madison together right now
because they were bad I don't think you
know when he was on watch what happens
lot but she was there oh okay I got I
understand let's just say the reunions
gonna be interesting did you film it yet
what the reunion oh and I look I feel
bad I don't want to you know I I don't
want to get down in the weeds and call
people names it's not it's not how I was
raised I but at the the core of it it
was my friend
I feel like was getting embarrassed
around town and I knew people were
whispering yeah and I knew what the
source of it was and I just didn't see a
whole hell of a lot of good energy
coming from their relationship yeah and
I have to back my friend so I really do
take back then I'd like to take back the
name-calling and the reunions gonna be
very hard for me because I'm not gonna
really know how to approach this whole
thing yeah and I really don't want to
tear somebody down honestly I just don't
I don't I would like to not have her in
anywhere in my life how about that and I
mean that doesn't mean negative I just
don't want her my life it's like a
hopefully an easy request but we'll see
how it shakes out he he obviously has
something between them and I don't
understand it and nobody understands it
yeah I know all his friends from his
hometown I don't have they're great
friends of mine too some of them some of
them I don't know as well but they're
all we're all friends nobody supports
their relationship not one single person
so it was almost like and I hate to say
this it was almost like they're on an
island and you know they're they cleaned
to each other yeah guess who else was on
an island clean to Thomas and Kathryn
and Ashley oh yeah yeah you know and I
don't I don't want to compare them
because it's not the same but I
understand that psyche I don't
personally understand it but I think
I've seen it before so maybe I think us
against the world
yes yes
exactly okay so um what put you in spot
for a minute because you and I just hang
out a bunch in Kentucky we had a great
time at somebody's wedding it was like
Ivy still hurts
do you ever be hurting my me know I
don't know what happened but the first
night I got so hammered I was running a
no one coming oh it's just like running
around Lexington like house that was fun
made a great time and you and on the it
was on this night where you apparently
injured your knee you made a promise me
and I don't know if you remember it but
now I'm singing on the air so um you
know I'm coming to Charleston yeah July
26 July 26 now you open though you did
stand up and you open for Rachel O'Brien
and you said you would open up my
chances of you know a know when we last
spoke you didn't have these plans what
is July 26 Margo can you look it up is
it us it's a Thursday I don't know it
sounds like a third it sounds very
Thursday ish feeling as though okay let
me let me move some things around
oh my god I'm trying to write a pilot
for a TV show in LA with these two
comedy writers look what we could do it
in Charleston with this company yeah I
am in favor you know I write
are you um what's the premise you miss
start no well no I'm not an actor
believe in her myself
oh yeah yeah no my friend came back from
Afghanistan he was in Special Forces and
he he was dishonorably our site just
honorably discharged a different yes and
he was like I sir might you know had
served my country and I'm about time I
say congratulations you made it I was
like we need to go on celebrate so I
called him a month later and he was like
I'm personal security for Jeff Bezos Wow
and I was like get out of here I was
like that's a TV show not necessarily
the pieces maybe make it an eccentric
billionaire yeah yeah and you come back
from Afghanistan and the premises the
the security detail is way more
dangerous and insane than Afghanistan
ever was yeah I think that there's
something there in the company so you
always have lots of ideas
have a hundred ideas I have another one
that you would like I think I think you
tell me about it Jim it's called
appearance yes yeah so it's actually
really interesting listen so i I've done
a few appearances I don't do as much as
like Jax and those guys they like Club
appearances not so well I went to a
casino in Atlantic City and they which
won an ungodly amount of money how much
12 K Wow just to show up and they got me
a private table and I was like I was
with my friend they drove him down I
mean they were so overly nice and we
were like in a private table I don't
think anybody cared I was not Atlantic
City I know early City is like the
bottom of the barrel white trash and you
aren't just like the upper echelon of
Charleston's society totally and another
one I went they were like Delta magazine
is hosting a work show and I thought our
lines would flee to Louisiana I was like
are they in Atlanta and it was like my
first year after the show and it was
Delta region the region the Louisiana
Delta I was like invest tanning bed goes
to oh and I stuttered these lines that I
had was redone next on the stage you
might remember him from season two of
redneck island
so I just I was like okay so there's the
premises you take someone like me or
y'all or like maybe an ex-athlete and
you you have to do the most like
potentially embarrassing appearance you
know where your fish out of water and
you see how they adapt and maybe they
have a great time maybe they want to
escape but that's that's the premise
generally just six behind like how much
would they have to pay you to go to like
your worst nightmare appearance yeah
yeah mine was a mere appearance it's
like a bikini contest you know yeah
you're literally ten million dollars
more like you know the head of a parade
like yeah yeah just so I think he'd be
good at that have you done that no but I
I think that would be funny and you meet
like there's this one guy that keeps
inviting me to a Packers game he's in
Wisconsin he's just
the show he's like come to Milwaukee man
we'll pick you up we'll go tailgating
I'm like like that would be hilarious to
fajn camera yeah yeah cuz she just got
mine in case they come in so I got lots
of ideas yes unfortunately in this
business an idea is hard to get to the
goal line
yeah but you'll see you get such an
interesting life these last few years
you think you'd be doing if it wasn't
you weren't on the show I'll tell you
what right before I got on the show I
was gonna franchise a fast-casual dining
Asian sort of rice bowl noodle bowl like
Hawaii sort of thing and I was gonna do
like two or three or four like stores
and they each make like 125 250 K so I
would have been like you know running
around shopping chopping chicken in the
wok wow I would have liked to see that
yeah yeah and I would have been happy
I'm sure yeah but this is better I think
how old you know 39 no you should say
wise you're very wise so when do you see
yourself I know everyone asks you this
like really moving out of the kids stuff
and starting a family yeah I do I might
sister brother both have that on this
lead like the whole hookup scene been
there done that doesn't give me any sort
of sense like sense of pride or like
self-worth like you know my twenties
like how'd you hook up last night yeah
bro like I don't that doesn't do it for
me anymore thank God yeah yeah you know
watching Jax and Brittany like it's
there's a certain kind of I think it's
cool with sort of check out of the game
in a timely manner yeah and make sure
it's the right course I would never do
it because of societal pressure yeah
what did you think of letting show a
good time I had a blast and honestly I
want to say and I think you'll agree
like the the cameras were not evasive
about it like it did not feel like a dog
and pony show like just videographer
like so I'd like to say good job Bravo
yeah we're stepping out very in the side
like even think the cameras were smaller
they were guys with big big old rigs so
it was classy deer I said it was love
that that castle was truly much I really
like Saturday night a lot I mean Friday
night was a [ __ ] mess
well Saturday the wedding oh yeah no
Friday night was so fun well at Friday
nights always a [ __ ] show at all
weddings right yes everybody gets
together everybody's excited to see each
other the shots start flowing in from
out of town yeah but Saturday no it was
great it was a beautiful wedding and she
looked beautiful and I had a great time
and I oh that's what everyone wants to
know did you or did you not hook up a
she nah he didn't we kissed a little bit
but that's it you know I told her I was
like looking you're great they're lovely
but like I just there was like a
pressure about it and I didn't feel
right to me pressure coming from where
everybody was like in a corner and I was
like I don't like this you're just gonna
slip out the back door nobody people to
shop in a corner nobody for the Shepherd
a quarter but yeah I just felt a little
forced and the cameras I didn't want to
become a story line on the wait I have
one last question for you are you with
any other girls from relationship not
really and now a year in hindsight what
are your thoughts on that show like
would you do then no well no I mean what
I wanted to do was different than what
got done and I don't like fault anybody
I mean if you want to give it a BR week
yeah I mean I wanted it to be more of
like an Anthony Bourdain dating show
like I just go to Bing Bing being all
these different cities in the United
States to show the different culture and
I was gonna be funny I'd like I was in I
you know all I want to do is comedy
honestly but um I opened my show and you
can't get your head in the door I know I
know so I it turned out they're more of
a bachelor facsimile and you know
whatever but I'll say this
if you judge by the public reaction
which is a dangerous thing to do but
it's also valid on a certain level
nobody hated it nobody was over the moon
about it so it was right down the middle
shows right there you know
the girls on the show right yeah we had
bail on the show I listened to that I
was pretty mad about that she refused to
be like I don't know she refused to be
like yeah I was a lot of fun Shep
treated us all like she was just sort of
I don't know just like she couldn't
verbalize yeah yeah how's the cat got
your Tony yeah would you so what does I
was really I mean I got Bella I've no
ill-will towards anybody off that show
thank you for coming on I know I mean
the heart the thing about that show was
I was doing five to six hours of improv
essentially with people that were bring
out the best in them and I had to give
my best it was exhausting yeah it was
exhausting yeah and I mean Bella I
helped her find a new job in the city
with a friend of mine owns a company I
mean and I was nothing but good and I
don't I don't need any Pat's on the back
but um I have no ill will towards any of
them for sure do you still talk to the
girl who was on last seats
another time yes yeah I see her from
time that she's feeling Charles yeah
shoes did she move there for you
I don't think so I think I don't know
when when your relationship show is on
Jackie had a really good call that you
thought you were gonna run away with
your producer do you still talk to her
we thought Jackie saw a spark there yeah
everyone I didn't I don't even I think
everyone was saying yeah well we're
great friends but she's a homebody she's
nothing like me in that regard but
there's another producer her best friend
that worked on our show - who we're way
like more flirtatious and yeah for
whatever reason anyway yes I always try
to set you up yeah it happened so those
two girls were were the producers and
season one of southern charm and they
were kind of in charge of me and I mean
we we had so much fun I mean I was like
a little kid I didn't know anything and
they were you got to be here you got to
do there and I we just had so much fun
I've met some of the most amazing people
that works on the show
honestly I'm going to Tahoe and one of
my friends will be out there that was on
season one as a producer we are very
close it wasn't us and all his buddies
are my buddies now so anyway it was a
good guy you know
just a happy guy yeah you a despite all
the rest of my class we got a question
because you were in New York with
Anastasia from below - yeah yeah and I
kind of ship it leaves marks fine well
see it Hannah and I ship no we were we
had been flirty on Twitter prior to
actually meaning okay and she had texted
me about asking questions about this and
the other and I was like huh she seems
like a lot of fun I don't know I don't
really watch the show I've watched like
maybe two episodes but she seems like a
pistol and I kind of like she's yeah
yeah
so we after their after their watch what
happens I went to meet them I didn't
know Anastasia was she's lovely though
and Hannah and I were like bouncing off
each other and then as everybody drank
more Hannah like oh she spilled a whole
martini all over herself and she went up
to change and me and Anastasia started
talking and then we got a cheese sticks
at a food truck and she jumped rope with
the cheese stick that she knew it was
really cool and I didn't try anything
but um but it is the old switcheroo well
we we had a we flirted and um I don't
know what I'm gonna do now because I
might like somebody right Yeah right
so you did she watches the - what
slipper I don't know what's she do at
all well she doesn't I'm not interested
what's a protocol be cool send a
follow-up text like don't be so loser II
like a million text messages like be
aware of the blue to gray ratio yes but
don't be a dick I'm not gonna be a dick
but don't don't not call yeah okay
I will no I will and I want to like I
find that I like if I like somebody like
I want to share all those goofy funny
thoughts I have yeah but I would like a
response and it also gives like so calm
okay so I Center Wow shy get into this I
said this is before we met this is
before we met cement over then took like
he's mad Lesley but you found each other
yes we had mutual friends
that's a great place to start yeah and
so I said I'm revealing too much it said
I was with my mom in the mountains and
we were watching a Beatles documentary
my mom was gushing about how much she
loved the Beatles and she was singing
along on all the songs and said she
bought every record and she Paul was her
favorite and I was just laughing I was
just kind of like imagining my mom is a
little Beatles fan right and I sent her
that text and I got like a crickets back
but she could have been asleep she are
busy or whatever but I don't think
that'll happen again because we had such
a good time last night do you think she
hasn't had as good at the time as you
did I know she did because I've met her
for coffee this morning and she's like
it was mutual their two dates yeah we
got a clock we split across town and got
iced coffee so romantic such a New York
moment so how long are you in New York
for an hour I leave this afternoon to go
to Tahoe and then LA for a couple weeks
and she lives here yes damn so what to
do what to do but good good good
problems I guess make sure you text but
don't text too much I don't do that
I'm not we had a great time lesson yeah
if you text too much you'll have nothing
to say yeah when you like talk about
everything then when you see each other
she already know everything like she's
she's sharp you're weirdly very
intelligent like people don't know that
about you but like I think everyone
knows yeah why do tulare yeah would you
get on the SATs 1,300 that's very good
yeah and then I went home for the summer
and the smartest scientist 11th grade
like ever ever since then it's been a
yeah because that's like I started
smoking a buncha we yeah drink into
excess so I went home for the summer
after I got 1,300
and just chiefed weed all summer and
came back and like literally made like a
five yeah it's not my name that's runner
voice well it has been an absolute
pleasure hey dude there's so much to
keep up follow you on Instagram at
relationship the new podcast is called
what enough about me enough about me
it's available on iTunes Spotify all the
places
that's why I'd also follow Craig the dog
it's it's good boy Craig great great
game good boy Craig he's 59,000 foul in
like a week and everyone at home just
say a little prayer that this works out
with Shep and his new wife oh stop okay
but yes it's good to be excited isn't it
just be excited I agree let's not put
too much pressure hey thank you guys for
tuning in make sure you listen to the
morning toast every Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube it's also available as a podcast
on Spotify iTunes stitcher all the
places you can listen to podcasts the
merch store is open for another 24 hours
that's www.hs calm we will see you on
Monday be this yang Tuesday because we
are headed to Vegas tomorrow for my
birthday and I'm gonna black out bye
you